you know what is up everybody prestige
here and first thing to do you just just
cook pork chops why I couldn't say words
okay hello everybody this is the I'm
gonna say yeah this I'm gonna say this
is the first episode of my new series
yeah my new series what now
but nestlings because there's no heron
and yeah my last year's hairpin series
and this is condemnations kind of that
but there's no more hair burn so he's
gone forever and yeah I break this know
I'm not gonna leave it there and so yeah
we are gonna continue on with the divine
RPG I'm not sure what I'm gonna call
this uh which I call not gonna call it
modded survival isn't it's like Ken's
particles all right I'll see in the
title what I call it but we have okay so
I've been doing some stuff since my last
upload and okay I've expended this tiny
bit that's no one cares about that over
here at the beach see I showed you guys
the crabs before and I had devised a way
or rather I found a way that other
people have uh uh hopefully these guys
don't get pissed off at me one sec
alright we good I've devised a way of
killing king crabs to get their leap so
you make a giant hole on each half
minute and you beat him with an infinite
or infinite durability sword until they
are no more I should really be doing
this with armor I was gonna go craft my
really might armor and you guys might be
wondering out with a heck did he get
real a mile think he's really my really
might is a tier higher than diamond in
terms of armor ratings I think the
pickaxes and tools stuff her diamonds
are better but yeah so did he be any
drops oh yes we got both those drops
alright he can drop aquatic pellet and
crab claws now he is the only source of
aquatic pellets and he and his little
butt oh you scared me little buddy right
there are the only sources of claws they
can be used to make weapons with aquatic
ingots which are formed you get nine
kwatak pellets you make them the
purified aquatic pellets then you heat
them up and you get aquatic ingots and
there's an aquatic ingot so throw that
in there and there
so let's crash some real might armor
some of the crafting is different like
you see for the chest piece it's a bats
I think legs are the same yeah then head
piece is that so it definitely takes a
lot more see I don't even have enough to
make a I don't have any room I don't
even have enough to make you don't have
a month yeah you see we got a damage
reduction so definitely some good stuff
and I'm going to enchant the chest
actually I'm going to get a book have
any books
I don't are dang I don't know leather I
wanted to make in the book oh well I
have thorns too so let's throw that on
the chest plate just play thorns - okay
I took some levels but levels really uh
oh that looks wudang snazzy snazzy all
the Kirchner's on the schnoz use now to
craft really light weapons you need real
like blocks which is uh sorry and a lot
which is nine of these so that's a waste
of money so I'm not going to do that
let's jump on some foods now you're
probably wondering why the heck do I
have golden pickaxes or butter pickaxes
the one guy one you say and as sky
minecraft skydoesminecraft' says but
butter put I made this spawner just
spawn mobs that spawn in light sometimes
they're here sometimes and all there
also is like two caverns connected where
it usually will get some people but it
looks like not today um let's go see
there there are two mop oh sorry
show y'all quiet there are two mobs that
drop real in my ingots one of them also
drops golden pickaxes that is the cave
klopse and I'm just looking around we
don't want to get ambushed by anybody I
don't see him here is yellow but I'm
seeing so oh there oh gosh no no no no
no no no no no no no oh dang if I had a
only boots but yeah that is the alt my
gosh wow okay that is the cave clops who
was the most freakin dangerous of the
ones I faced or doesn't the most damaged
or maybe just Wow myself one everywhere
[Applause]
he he has right he has ranged damage so
that might be why he's the most
threatening okay he has beaten be in the
feet begin the feet okay so I basically
ow whenever I fight a cape clops this is
how my thing goes for the other ones I
can just hit them I can hit them back
but for this guy since he has ranged I
can't really just spam click him so that
he can't hit me since he can't even hit
me when he's gonna smack so I kinda just
had to do this he has some pretty high
aggro range
oh wow jumped pretty good pretty cool
why is running away okay flops
I run away come at me bro Wow Wow no no
no don't let him hit me oh dang he might
be able to get in
oh who else goes my king this king armor
so legit okay let's let's patch this up
so he can all nope nope no I think we're
safe okay so this is probably one of the
toughest battles I've seen from the cave
cops because I usually don't fight them
like this usually uh I fight them like
say I'm in here and they're out here and
I just beat them but this is like around
a corner so it's all funky okay okay um
it's block out that Brizzy come on come
over here I'm gonna take a few hits
there we go so one more hit will do him
in okay there we go
dropping it yeah okay we see he does see
you see the golden because he just tons
of golden pickaxes which is alright
because uh they lag because they break
in about the really fast so they're like
good Pat another cake pops come on Susie
or something come on come on come on
there's one fight oh gosh don't want to
fight me new boy trapped
oh I've to risk letting him out
things gonna be hard Wow no screw this
or not
screw you bruh you don't want my help
then you don't get it okay
let's pop this back off and see how this
can since cave clops and the other thing
I dropped real amazing gets spawn in
full light that's why I lit up the
things so other mobs don't spawn so I
don't want other mobs and let's just do
a quick look thought I saw something
oh and also cool little thing that one
of the mobs that I that I've been
fighting drops a dia Mons so diamonds
are very really that useful like the I'm
not picking up his iron be as a do I
want to not really because iron isn't
that good
I cannot mine it why does it take three
years to mine gold not mine iron gold
mine gold nope Nicole NK well oh I guess
the gold is all the attributes of a
wooden one except is better okay okey
doke
well the one I couldn't iron regardless
let's see no Braun was looking for some
of the logs you'd like to show them to
you guys because they pick now to not
show up see like you hear that we still
got the cave clumps on there I want to
show you that guy every sound it sounds
like is it like far above
oh no he's right there are they've got a
cave crawler he's the other guy who
dropped me with my ingots and you see
I'm pretty good able to keep him back
and they drop out and drop but he can
drop zero to two real I think it's I
think so if I had looting this would he
be even better but all right now we'll
have just survived with to read on my
with the did not looting that I'm got
like a bad amount of drops like the cave
cops can drop zero to six so I like him
the best
except he else is also the hardest skill
they get on you getting everything its
sadness select smart mobs one thing also
slash mine you've no I don't really need
a mine anymore really the other thing I
need is cold to cook the stuff up that I
like you mine I also uh last episode I
showed you my like nether thing I I
should decorate that with another rack
today I'll do that
alright let's get us another rack I want
some more netherrack oh wow oh hello
fight fight fight fight so yeah down
with another another area
alright so let's break all this and
start replacing it with netherrack take
a bit of a good good good another home
feeling dizzy inspector together theme
song so yeah cool news the end is on
minecraft on xbox so that's good I tried
get up I forgot about how weak they are
I tried getting some footage except
something went wrong with my recording a
device my HD PVR so I'm gonna have to do
it oh my gosh how fast oh my gosh that's
amazing I don't have to do that again
but yeah since I came out today so I'll
be doing creative shot of that for you
guys just to see what it's like and
listen out all the stuff so chances are
you've already seen you either already
seen that video or it's already been out
and you just haven't seen it which if
that's the case then I suggest going to
see it since it should be a pretty
awesome video even though I haven't made
it yet hopefully future me
to fulfill fulfills my promises of a
good video
if he doesn't gonna have to beat him so
it takes a bit to break Kabul don't
worry still have three more see I just
want to make this all netherrack for
just to make it look more like nether
--is-- it's like my nether room I was
gonna say I wonder if they breaks
obsidian fast but being like a wooden
pickaxe it wouldn't be able to break
obsidian since if you guys haven't
realized it it's not just realised this
episode it has the attributes of a
wooden pickaxe it's just a lot faster
and let's start well yeah I'm gonna need
to pick you thank you thank you
but IQ but IQ no oh I didn't mean your
place there break you break you and get
some light in here let's get some light
in here oh my gosh don't know where I'm
clicking okay why can i still more gold
pickaxes so oh I'm so good under the
rack so good break these
the walls and stuff Hoopa doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo hope you guys enjoyed
the little mobs that I had to do so now
that we have really my or almost have a
full set of real in my armor we is it
it doesn't say full set for 8.25% and
reduction it just says that in general
so hopefully that's good yeah these
things have like 33 uses so terrible and
break break break I think this is gonna
be it's awesome a completely another
eyes room for the nether portal
oh no we almost forgot you Oh someone's
here my door oh it might be my friend
all right guys I'm gonna in this video
here hope you all enjoyed hopefully it
wasn't too short if you did leave like
comment rate subscribe and peace out
guys